What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience?
Nope.
Do you take hormones or anything or no.
No,
but I could,
I could transition,
but then I've got this,
I've got these boy genetics going on in me.
I really think it's jeans.
I think they're going to find out how it works,
but I can't prove that at the moment.
But if I transition over,
then I'll just be on the other side of this kind of fence that we give
ourselves.
And I've decided,
okay,
I'm gender fluid.
I'm just going to have like a superhero boy mode and girl mode.
Like the human torch can go flame on the flame off.
So I'm going,
when do you do decide?
Some days today I'm boy mode.
I can,
but I tend to,
uh,
I do sort of block periods now,
but what I campaign,
I mean girl mode,
but I'm doing films,
dramatic films.
I've been boy mode.
Um,
and I suppose a transgender character to think about it.
Not Ready now,
but it's easy for me to be in girl mode because then if I can,
if I can deal with that.
And you know,
some people stare at you and I have a confidence now I carry myself with a
certain confidence.
They go,
oh,
he seems to be quite confident.
So I'm just relax about that and I can,
I can actually,
I can control other people's that embarrassment because if they don't know what
to do,
I'd say,
hi,
how are you?
Can I have a cup of tea?
Oh yeah.
Well we sell to,
oh no,
that's why you're here.
I don't know.
Okay.
So I can just relax people by just chatting to them.
Um,
and then boy meds quite easy for me to do cause I just,
I just right to just be yourself.
I scrub up quite well.
And boy,
do you have you but you've given thought to transitioning.
Yup.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
you know,
the part of me wants to be,
um,
Steve McQueen and greatest skate and part of me wants to be Elizabeth Taylor in
looking like a home in a cat and he was afraid of Virginia Woolf there cat on a
hot tin roof,
more like,
which I just saw on the plane yesterday.
So these are the two books like go over to another guy.
Well I kind of both of them and as a kid I thought you know,
kind look more like Clinton,
uh,
at the,
the Steve McQueen because I kind of fascinated with Steve McQueen and they,
well he went through to get to where he was and he was so driven.
I don't actually know about this Steve McQueen story because you know that he
was in a film with Paul Newman and he was like 93rd on the list of credits
somewhere.
Someone up there likes me.
If you watch it,
you can see him.
There's a knife fight between pulling him and Steve Mcqueen and he's like a
heavy,
you know,
young thug hit kind of heavy guy,
but he's just a small player.
And then the second phone he's in with them is tiring and fair now where they
are equal billing and I think Paul Newman is first and Steve McQueen is higher.
If you look at,
if you look at the names on the poster,
Paul Newman comes in from the left,
so he's named his first.
Steve McQueen is on the right bar higher than full,
uneven.
That's how they got that equal billing without,
you know,
how do you put equal billing if you're going to stop for the light reading from
the left,
right.
But,
uh,
and if you remember the film,
they come at it as two,
two guys,
you say?
Yeah.
That both decent guy there.
These are both heroes.